thank you very much for your kind
remarks and let me be burst
great victory whose support for so many
years as the mayor is like our entire
family Vermont
thank you our Kim Clinton has won for
that
point four million Americans at rallies
in almost every state lesson that I have
learned or any other candidate who
sought the presidency this campaign is
about the needs of the American people
and addressing
and want us to forget where we were
seven and a half years ago
when President Obama came into office as
a result of the greed recklessness and
illegal behavior on Wall Street 3,000
people a month of collapse we have come
a long way in the last seven and a half
years and I thank President Obama and
President Biden for their leadership in
pulling us out of that terrible
recession by needs to be done this
election is about that woman and the
millions of other workers in this
country who are falling further and
further behind as they try to survive on
totally inadequate wages in America that
is rigged and that sends almost all of
the new wealth and income to the top one
percent that person should not be living
in poverty and to a living wage building
our crumbling infrastructure our roads
our bridges our water systems our
wastewater plants he has a very
different view the minimum wage or even
abolish the concept of the minimum wage
starvation wage who offered the
disastrous Citizens United decision
we'll defend a woman's right to choose
and what that means the civil liberties
equal rights and the future of our
country or under ensuring to choose a
public option in their health care
exchange dental care mental health
counseling and low cost prescription
drugs dentists and other medical
professionals practice in underserved
areas as we follow through on President
Obama's idea of tripling funding for the
National Health Service health centers
will do and that is what getting medical
personnel into the areas we need them
most
will do he wants to abolish the
Affordable Care Act more people with
access to quality health care not fewer
of prescription drugs Medicare must
negotiate drug prices with the
pharmaceutical industry while one out of
five Americans are unable to afford the
medicine they need an effective tax rate
higher than hedge fund millionaires I
have met throughout this country who
I've left college deeply in debt the
many others who cannot afford to go to
college
and that we must make public colleges
and universities to wish in yes they
will be able to get a college education
and leave school without that energy
efficiency and sustainable energy
something no presidential candidate
should ever do this election and repair
a broken criminal justice system of
eighty billion dollars a year men and
women young and all but I am happy to
tell you that at the Democratic platform
committee which ended Sunday night in
Orlando there was a significant coming
together between the two campaigns and
we produced we produced by far the most
progressive platform in the history of
the Democratic Party